all right so it's time to talk about
everybody's favorite topic
oh no
[Music]
hey everybody and welcome to council of
geeks and
i'm going to talk about today something
that
the perspective that i am in particular
coming at this from is an lgbtq plus
perspective but i think it applies to
a lot of things outside of that actually
which normally is the case when i tackle
these things i have a tendency to tackle
things that you can extrapolate and
apply what i'm saying to
other areas or other groups as well at
least
in part so um i've had this one on my
to-do list for a while
addressing the idea or the question of
why is the mere inclusion
of certain groups of people inherently
considered to be political
now here's the funny thing about this
topic
i've been sitting on this for a while
and when i first
jotted down the idea of in some way
tackling this what i
thought i was gonna be focusing on was
talking about how
the inclusions of lgbtq plus people
disabled
people uh neurodivergent people racially
diverse people is not inherently
political why the heck do people feel
the need to make it that
but that's um that's not where i'm going
with this
because well
it is political but i think there's
still things for me to talk about there
including covering why it is political
so first of all something that you need
to accept
going in is that everything
has a political aspect to it
how much of that is intended or
deliberate that will vary but there is
always a political aspect
to everything it does not matter what it
is even if that political aspect
is simply the mindset and the framework
and the understanding and base
assumptions and political background and
inherent
biases of the people creating the piece
of work whether it be the writer
directors
whatever it is their political
background and understanding
influences what they do and how they
come at these things
even if those political views are not
directly injected into the work
everything everything
that is made to be consumed including
art because i don't care how artsy it is
it's still intended to be viewed by
somebody has a political aspect and if
you are not prepared to accept that i
honestly don't know how to have this
conversation with you
but assuming that you can go with me
that far
accepting that there is a political
element to everything
let's talk specifically about the
politics of inclusion
and why or at least my perspective
on why because i'm not an expert
the it is such a sticking point
especially in internet discourse and
geek internet discourse
in particular much to my chagrin
well the first thing that really needs
to be addressed
is in some ways the language i run into
this every now and then that sometimes
part of the problem is the way that we
talk about things
and just the fact that the term
political correctness exists
is part of why people when they see
inclusion shake a finger and go politics
because we actually have the word
political right in the thing that
we use as an umbrella that these that
this sort of thing falls under
now political correctness was a term
originally coined in the 70s and
originally it was much more about the
specifics about
how someone was portrayed as opposed to
their mere
inclusion and presence at all but at
this point especially in terms of
popular use it absolutely all falls
under that same umbrella but i kind of
want
to shove that term aside
forget the fact that the word politics
exists in this
term that is not what makes it political
because that's just the language just
that's just what we use to describe it
that does not inherently mean that that
word
is the best thing that we should be
doing or is indicative of exactly what
it is we're dealing with
but as i said at the front end inclusion
is political acknowledging the existence
of a group especially a minority or
underprivileged or underrepresented
group
is inherently a political thing to do
again not always done with a political
intent
but including them still make some kind
of political statement
about the work or if you're working in a
piece of fiction about the world you
have created
i ran into this with the novel that i
had my kickstarter for kickstarter's
wrapped up
at this point but i will put
announcements out when the books avail
eventually available for pre-order and
all that i'm still working through a lot
of stuff
i got a lot of things i got to do with
that but in the process of working in
that a
very interesting thing happened
especially once i got it into the hands
of my
editor now when they were going over it
they took note and and i didn't what was
great was i didn't ask them to do this
this is just part of their process and
it's actually part of why i
will highly recommend them as an editor
once they're free and available
again or if they are now uh teresa grabs
you know what i'll put a link in the
description they're great
but the the thing is is that i very
deliberately made some specific choices
in terms of inclusions
of uh lgbtq plus characters or at least
ones that
could be read that way and wanted that
to be
part of the world that i was building
that was a deliberate choice
with a political element by me
what teresa ended up pointing out to me
was the fact that i had failed
to include anything that indicated that
there was
disability access because i had a couple
of locations where there were references
to stairs and no mention of
ramps which means that without meaning
to
simply because i didn't think about it i
didn't account for it i had created a
world where
those specific locations if not the
society and the world in general that i
had depicted
doesn't make accommodations for
physically disabled people
and that me that has a political element
because it means that
in the politics of this well it meant
before i addressed it because
i actually didn't want that as a
background element
um but what it meant at the time at the
revision that
they looked at it meant that i had
created a world
where the political choice had been made
to not go out of the way
to accommodate these people in certain
spaces
that would have been in universe a
political decision
and my failure to account for that had
political implications
and made inferences about the world even
though i didn't realize that i'd done
that
again tying back to the fact that
everything is political
and so now my decision to
try and amend that and include some
references that make it clear that at
the very least some spaces
are being catered to for people with
possible movement
disabilities that is now in there and my
decision to include that
is political because it means something
in the context of the politics of the
world i have created for this book
but here's the thing i really want to
dig into
because it is true inclusion
is political but you know what we don't
talk about
we don't talk about the flip side of
that which is the fact that a
lack of inclusion is also political
generally speaking it is framed as
only being political when what are
considered to be minority groups
are depicted in a work be it
film tv video game novel whatever
that is considered to be political but
because we don't say that same thing
about the inclusion of what is generally
the default template
and that template in western culture
historically and still
currently is generally male
white heterosexual cisgender
and able-bodied and we consider anything
that doesn't that deviates on any of
those five points or
certainly if it deviates from all of
them to be in a way political but we
don't talk about
there being politics behind someone who
matches all five
that's taken as a given that is taken as
being
apolitical it's not
and that's my big frustration with this
entire framing of
including people who aren't all five of
those things is in some way political
fails to recognize the fact that not
including them
is also political that's my big
frustration more than anything else
because i'm not going to argue
anymore i may have at one point but i'm
no longer going to argue from the
position
of including people of
other skin tones or body sizes or shapes
or ability levels or sexualities or
gender identities
isn't political because it is
i am however immediately gonna push back
and say so is not including them
everybody in every society has their
base assumption that's
why i brought up the issue of my failure
to account for disability in the world i
created in my novel
because i'm an able-bodied person
i've never had to deal with physical
disability and so unless i really go out
of my way to account for it i don't
think about it
and therefore it's not there because
that is my normal
that is to me the default
but just because it's my default doesn't
rob it
of political implication it's still
there
again whether i intend it or not whether
i recognize it or not whether i fully
understand
the meaning of those implications or not
they are still present
they are still there which is another
element when people say
well i didn't want to be political so i
just made everybody a white man if
somebody does that the fact that they
think
that that makes it apolitical is
incredibly politically revealing
about what they view as being normal
or what they view as the standard
and your assumptions about
what is normal what is standard and what
is
a deviation or an intrusion in from that
is incredibly informed
by your political background your
political understanding
your political biases and your political
blind spots
because we all have them
i everybody has some area that is
affected by politics that we just don't
understand or don't
think to account for unless it's brought
up by somebody else
what that is will vary wildly how many
blind spots
people have that will also vary but we
all have them
and that is why ultimately i am 180
degrees in the opposite direction of
where i thought i was going to end up on
this issue
which is not the position that i thought
i would be coming from which is
these things are not political stop
acting as if they are
no instead these things are political
stop acting as if their absence
isn't political this ultimately is me
venting a little bit at
the discourse which is ultimately me
howling into the wind
i understand that i am a
small youtuber i can't
change the way people are having these
conversations
and i you know even setting aside bad
actors who are going to
twist things for their own purposes
anyways even people talking in good
faith i can't control that conversation
but
i can still put out there and have it on
the record
my stances on these things and try to
get people to understand where i'm
coming from and maybe get them to think
about things in a way they didn't before
the way i've had to do with lots of
things
in my life not just my creative works
there are lots of things i've had to
have my eyes opened about to realize
that my assumption that my normal
isn't political is fundamentally
wrong nothing
is a political deal with it
so there you go
i don't know how much of this is
ultimately going to be helpful for other
people or how much of it is just
me doing this for myself but
i hope you found that interesting
thoughtful
entertaining i don't know whatever your
thoughts are i hope you will drop
something down in the comments
and allow us to talk about it be
respectful that is my one
rule i don't care what your position is
if you're a jerk
to me or anyone else you will be gone
that's how it works
i have a patreon which is how this
channel is able to
exist and it's how i am able to eat it's
what keeps the lights on around here
and in addition to that there are all
the usual things that you can do to help
me out as well like
share subscribe and all those wonderful
things like links down in the
description if you are in need of an
editor
check out teresa they are amazing and
all the other links besides for merch
and twitters and so forth but you also
don't
have to because at the end of the day
you
are the council and i am only
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
bye